so remember i said this way we begin
this is just the statement the expansion
out of like that distances these two
points that distance is perpendicular
one I see that I've got an e / this eat
right well it's actually the absolute
value of e but he is a ratio of positive
number so that's why I can cancel those
thumbs up and then when you got this 0y
disappear you can see this is enormous
symmetry here that's going to indeed and
their way to factorize a whole lot when
I get down ok now after I square both
sides what ends I happen is you have to
collect some like terms the important
thing is have a look at what I buck here
okay how do I know to get to this out of
my like you end up getting a mess of
terms in these couple of individuals
there isn't wise because i'm aiming at
this i may be the next webinar y squared
separated out so that's why i get x
squared + y square I factorizing those
terms luckily for me there's only a
single y squared and then i have this
now i only need one more step to get to
what I'm supposed to be right i need to
divide by whatever is that so i get one
on the right hand side by side exits so
when i do that the one minus e Squared's
cancel here so you just get left with 8x
squared on a swears alright and then you
get this
and you say wait a minute that wasn't
what I was supposed to get right because
I was expecting something else pause
actually you should have expected this
because what do I put into this we put
in all A's and E's you can't just
magically have Abby come out of it as i
get a wild B squared appeared right it's
not going to do that because what you
input is 0 all as it is that's why
that's all in terms of this but we
already know we already know that this
in fash should be B squared so remember
how we were trying to get e right well
if you know a and B there's a
relationship between these three values
right memory b squared is equal to a
squared times 1 minus square put a big
freshman box around that bag okay as a
huge it off we had to go through a lot
of work to get all the way there this is
the key finally made it this is what's
going to unlock the original question
okay and if you remember this was the
original person this is what sets us on
this wild goose chase in the first place
right what do I do with this thing how
do i how do I interpret this
and use this yeah nice 16a squared yeah
yep Benny you're like 92 full 150 square
thank you yeah fantastic okay I don't
even need to like think well what's the
square root of that it's full because in
fact what I want is a squared b squared
back so I'm Chuck a bit watch right this
is going to be joy equals 16 x 1 minus B
Square yep then you to buy 3 9 161 make
where you swear what i do now i need to
i need to subtract x from both sides and
then
so this is going to become negative 760
and I've got a double negative on both
sides so I get that I've just run out of
space but that means that a which is a
ratio drunk again so that's why I can
ignore the negative solution is going to
be negative sorry route 7 on for right
and I would say it's because he is going
to do these operations yeah it's ratio
between somebody's so that's pretty cool
notice by the way are two things number
one this is not a half do you remember
the first ellipse we did we were trapped
in a half and then it out of the
knowledge right this is that a half what
is root cellar on four legs open
and what's the decimal zero toilet seats
book yeah
okay so it's not a half but it's still
an ellipse right so 0.5 is wealthy elite
it's going to give this list that will
give us much as well I wonder what other
values it would still give me an ellipse
explore that too I can use this i'm just
going to take it now k i'm going to use
it to solve original pleasure i can at
last right because i know where the
director sees are there are plus or
minus 4 on that right
director sees our x equals plus or minus
4 divided by ya go back it's interesting
someone yeah so I'm going to get that
looks to be like plus or minus 16 on 37
yeah those are two equations that I've
after right now just double check right
um calculator again what is 16 / except
just giving positive one obviously the
negative ones same magnitude what is it
was 6.04 going back to your original
diagram you knew where the x-intercepts
work remember that plus or minus four
now you've got plus or minus 6.5 does
that look about right I kind of is it
the right neighborhood isn't it just a
bit further okay in the same way I can
work out what the [ __ ] I on the third
guy are
plus or minus AE come 0 right that's
plus or minus a is for we already said
that times root 7 on for so gets a nice
canceling their first enemy right so
you're just getting plus or minus root 7
comma 0 z red seven that's somewhere
between root for Andrew ninth between
two and three so it's like to point
something ish stupid something it which
is again just do the check right oh yeah
that's about there on those two spots on
the ellipse that's where you expect to
pro ties be all right take a deep breath
take a derail you've established online
remember I gave you some cheats earlier
wrong one I know we took the long way to
get there but that's because we knew
nothing about any of these chase before
we're just done the first question what
a yes ok that is that is seriously the
first question sketch each ellipse and
five its foot higher and director seals
no no I don't think no you know we did
enter we'd have to go through all of
these lips so remember how I said put a
box around it my best luck to everybody
um this now you don't need to prove this
ever again thank goodness it took us
like an overhaul okay it's a big deal as
a lot of geometry in there we just use
this now right so if you have a wonder
one being for instance like this is
actually this over here this is the
whole amount of work a squared + B
squared are sitting there ready for you
to evaluate okay so you just pop them
into your heart and you'll get
for the eccentricity once you've done
that each elementary to find out what
interspecies and proton are all right
why don't any intersubject took really
good question two reasons one of which
you will not find out until you make
some headway to get sighs not because
the exercise tell you how much I just
wanna stop talking not showing so much
theory the second reason is because well
actually like there's a parasite um my
eccentricity is not always the thing
i'll try to get out of this right and
sometimes like you will find this
equation actually changes for when we
look at some of these other clinics or
whatever they are right so therefore
this is the most helpful form to
distinguish between them you can write
it with these squares a subject with the
line but i wouldn't encourage it because
you start to confuse all the different
regions with each other these best have
one